the mating ritual OLOL each species on
earth has certain well peculiarities as
you might tell from the name of the
species itself blue footed boobies are
no exception to this rule here in the
Galapagos Islands this pair of blue
footed boobies check each other out
now what is the most important quality
the female looks for in a male good
looks a steady income beachfront
property well those are important but
they pale in comparison to having blue
feet hence this dance the revelation of
foot color so that the female will not
by mistake mate with a red footed
earlier or even a plan to put in booty
now let's say don't an iguana wanders
into booty land the boobies tend to
breed where the marine iguanas spend the
night
so this iguana does have a reason to be
here not that the boobies care they
force the poor iguana to run a gauntlet
of pecking beats heck out heck out hey
let me out of here man this is worse
than a fraternity hazing
[Music]
the Iguana finds its way out which I
guess in this case you could say is the
out booby prize
yeah sorry